[Applaudissements]
après on connaît l'histoire puisque on
n'écoute plus europe 1 vous l'avez pas
fait sur rtl je le sais je dors entendu
ces gros temps de cuivre lac russe notre
stagiaire qui s'incruste dans le maximum
d'émissions bien sûr diggle musicale
[Musique]
on aime bien mais bien sûr clémence et
stagiaires de la rédac de touche pas à
mon poste or là ici sur l'image quand il
était venu nous voir et comme beaucoup
de stagiaires on n'a rien trouvé à lui
faire faire c'est le principe d'un
stagiaire
du coup on a décidé de l'envoyer
s'incruster dans le plus d'émissions
possible pour le tenir bien éloignée du
bureau et il est encore bien bossé cette
semaine regarder on l'a vu à l'avant
première parisienne du nouveau spider
man mange une pomme à la cool derrière
les stars du film tombe à l'eau
on l'a ensuite vu sur ma chaîne sport
dans l'émission de taïg khris en train
de boire un coup à la route
montre nous c'est parti soeur mais où
[Musique]
grâce à la télé on a appris que clément
commencé à pécho on l'a vu pendant qu'il
s'incruste est sûre cette interview
ouais moi tu plais du mail à améliorer
et à et en fait on a cédé par un style
est entre les deux
et encore la vue sur bfm télé par un
duplex devant le palais de justice
déguisés pour passer à choisir de vivre
réellement très cher puisque le fonds de
garantie qui indemnise les victimes peut
ensuite se retourner contre le
conducteur fautif mouvement l'argent
tombe pas la revoir cela parce que c'est
là aussi attend quand c'est presque
négrier pas qu'il agit de se déguiser